close your eyes
see with mine
hi there my name is Elizabeth Keenan and
I was the set decorator on a wrinkle in
time this was the second project that I
got to do with Ava we had a good rapport
me kind of had the same taste and we
understand each other's references so
that's really nice to have that shortcut
with a director our process with set
decoration is we're basically visual
storytellers and what we do is break
down a script and make all your notes
sets to things that you think might
contribute to kind of a visual treatment
to push that story along we are in
search of warriors our contribution to
visual storytelling is furnishings
artwork drapery lighting fixtures that
are seen on set down to small little
details what's in drawers what are on
counter tops so we do lots and lots of
research and we figure out who these
people are who these characters are and
how can we tell the audience about them
visually be hard okay for me the most
important sets were the ones that were
based on Earth the Murray house the
Murray lab the James Baldwin middle
school the graphics that went into that
school
walking into the imax theater I mean I
didn't realize how giant the screen was
it's huge and then the music comes up
and it's just bounding and beautiful and
and you really get absorbed into all the
interesting textures and layers that are
happening and it's just wonderful to see
everyone up close and hold it you can
see the details so beautifully and
crisply and it looks better than I
remember so I I can't wait to see it big
the only thing faster than light
it's a darkness
[Music]